I feel like I had to to go through the
worst possible heartbreak ever I just
think that needed to happen
and ultimately it was the best thing
that ever happened Selena Gomez reflects
back on her split from Justin Bieber and
how it shaped who she is today very
happy for him I know honestly the two
dated in a highly publicized on and off
relationship from 2011 to 2018 and in
her new Apple TV plus documentary my
mind and me she gets candid about going
their separate ways saying it was the
best thing that ever happened to her I
did want people to see what it's like
for a young woman
to you know have a have a relationship
come to Define her and have a
relationship where the media is
constantly saying outrageous things to
her
um and you talk about voices in your
head you know she had voices in her head
but some of those voices were coming
from the outside in it shortly after the
two called it quits for the Last Time
Justin reconciled with his then ex Haley
Bieber whom he married in 2018.
someone wants to replace us like it was
easy
[Music]
and in 2020 Selena released her hit
track lose you to love me a track widely
speculated to be about the aftermath of
her relationship with the singer
[Music]
lose you to love me
Selena says she wrote that song in Just
45 minutes
the song is about knowing that you
completely lost every part of who you
are just to ReDiscover yourself again
[Music]
by a past relationship that no one
wanted to let go
but then I just
moved past it
and I wasn't afraid anymore and with the
release of the documentary comes new
music from Selena too him constantly
trying to fight
[Music]
my mind and me we don't get along
sometimes and she teases to E.T more
music is coming that is the goal is
being able to write these stories that
are happening in my life now because
it's been years since I've released
music so so many beautiful things have
happened and I can't wait to tell that
through music
[Music]